que l'ennui et cruelle cruellement
ennuyeux je ne sais pas de termes plus
fort ni plus vrai car seul le semblable
se reconnaît au semblables s'il y avait
un mot plus noble plus expressif il y
aurait du mois encore un mouvement à
faire mais je reste étendue inactif la
seule chose que je vois c'est le vide
la seule dont je vis c'est le vide le
seul milieu où je me me
c'est le vide je ne ressens même pas les
souffrances même la douleur a perdu pour
moi ça vertus apaisantes
si l'on m'ouvre est toutes les
splendeurs où tous les tourments du
monde comme ces choses me sont également
indifférente
je ne me tournerai pas de l'autre côté
ni pour les atteindre
ni pour les fuir je meurs de mort
c'est pas de moi cette cascade
[Musique]
lars svensson un philosophe norvégien
nous explique qu'on s'ennuie dans
plusieurs cas de figure quand attend
quelque chose si tu hâtive perdre à
cause de la haute idée trop au boulot et
netflix ou de tous bords damas fred
chichin
ou encore quand tu dois faire quelque
chose de nouveau
et que tu y arrives pas jouer thibauld
en fait tu t'ennuies très très très
souvent il doit sûrement y avoir une
solution pour que ça s'arrête à la leo
leo c'est un mec comme ça
a priori il s'ennuie jamais et si lui ne
s'ennuie jamais il sera le mieux placé
pour m'aider à arrêter de m'ennuyer
demandé je suis mieux placé pour t'aider
à la tête par mes mecs j'ai trop peur de
m'ennuyer pour nous c'est normal mais
qui sont annulés c'est la pire chose au
monde c'est pas humain
thomas ce que je fais pour pas m'ennuyer
c'est que je suis en train de toujours
de faire des trucs de ouf non permanents
soit le jour on était au guatemala et
bim éruptions ont été filmés ça a été
copiée qu'est ce que j'ai fait je fais
une petite brasse dans le lac de lave
est incroyable ensuite bon ok il
s'ennuie jamais un problème raconte sa
vie où je me fais chier alors vraiment
c'est drôle ça maintenant que j'y pense
les gens qui s'ennuient pas ils sont
toujours chiant alors que les gens qui
s'ennuient sont plutôt intéressants en
général et du coup bah c'est comme ça
que j'ai [ __ ] mon cousin
les homes a proposé un programme de
désintoxication de l'ennui sur mesure on
a fait plein de trucs ensemble
il lâche tout fait pour pas que je
m'ennuie genre de soirée des activités
comme de l' escalade faire de la musique
mais aussi des soirées mater youtube
faire des jeux vidéo et des soirées en
fait beaucoup de soirées et peut-être
même un petit peu trop mais ça m'a
permis de regarder les eaux et de
comprendre
il est plus malade que moi il n'est pas
guéri de l'ennui bien au contraire il
est dépendant des divertissements les
voyages les soirées les films le sexe
puis il se divertit plus il a besoin de
l'être et ça ne s'arrêtera pas il aura
toujours peur de s'ennuyer à nouveau
rien qu'une seconde
en fait ce sera même de pire en pire à
cause de l'adaptation hédonique en gros
peu importe les événements positifs ou
négatifs ou les changements majeurs dans
notre vie on revient assez vite à un
niveau de bonheur stable on pense qu'on
sera plus heureux en ayant une certaine
voiture ou une certaine maison une fois
qu'on l'a on revient vite au niveau de
bonheur initial c'est pour ça qu'un
autre terme c'est les données que près
de 1000 en anglais le tapis roulant
hédonique en fait on croit courir sur la
route du bonheur mais on fait du
surplace
léo il est comme tout le monde en fait
comme vous comme moi il a peur
cet ennui l'humanité le fuit depuis
toujours on ferait n'importe quoi pour
pas s'ennuyer tout est meilleur que
l'ennui même la souffrance c'est à cause
de ça qui est les conflits les
persécutions les guerres bertrand
russell disait qu'au moins la moitié des
péchés de l'humanité sont provoqués par
la peur de l'ennui
une vie trop remplie d'excitation c'est
une vie épuisante
non seulement ça affecte la santé en
plus de ça ça rend tout fade
parce que rien ne nous suffit plus se
divertir n'est donc pas la bonne
solution
les satisfactions profonde et naturels
sont remplacés par de ridicule stimuli
incapable de combler le vide
on peut être sûr stimuler et quand même
s'ennuyer fondamentalement s'ennuyer
d'être donc peut-être que kierkegaard a
raison peut-être que l'ennui c'est pas
l'absence de divertissement non c'est
l'absence de sens et si je ne peux m'en
débarrasser alors je dois l'accepter
ce vide il ne se comble pas il se guérit
pas ils s'apprivoisent c'est dans
l'ennui lui-même que je dois trouver ce
sens dans les eaux trouve du sens dans
son ennui [ __ ] et tous ceux qui n'ont
pas appris à apprivoiser cet ennui ne
seront jamais complet on a besoin de
ressentir l'ennui il fait partie
intégrante de la nature de l'humain et
ce n'est pas en allant de divertissement
en divertissement on arrivera à échapper
non seulement parce que c'est impossible
mais surtout parce que vouloir éviter
l'ennui c'est fuir notre véritable
nature
bon après abu toi quand même
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
c'était la facette d'une problématique
vous trouverez l'autre facette sur la
chaîne de léo grasset s'appelle dirty
biologie mais un lien juste en dessous
et peut être même là on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine même jour même heure
donc jeudi 18h pour une nouvelle vidéo
qui va allier à la fois la philosophie
et l'humour vous en dit pas plus et
d'ailleurs la maman je reprends un
rythme de production hyper régulier avec
au moins une vidéo par semaine les
jeudis à 18 merci beaucoup on se revoit
la semaine prochaine lors pis
[Musique]